I think one massive problem with the
direction the United States has gone and
really over the past hundred years is to
create an analogy we've gone from a
neighborhood to an apartment building so
when you're in a neighborhood everyone
has their own house they have their own
lawn they can make decisions about their
house they can add something on to it
subtract something from it have a garden
not have a garden on chickens whatever
it is right in your all houses you're
all in the neighborhood you all have the
same zip code but you're able to make
decisions about your own property
there's some sovereignty there might be
an HOA that puts some limitations on it
but overall you can make your own choice
for your own property now it's like the
United States has become a condominium
and each state is its own little condo
and you're able to make decisions and
it's technically your own property as a
state or as the governor of a state or
as the people of estate but you're not
fully Sovereign because
there's a certain pattern you have to
follow so that you don't move outside of
the status quo of what is like
architecturally sound for that building